JOHN HANKE: So I'm
going to introduce
James Frey, who's here to talk
about his book, "Endgame."
We've got a bunch of people from
the Niantic team here-- very
cool.
My name is John Hanke.
For you guys that
don't know me, I've
been at Google for
over 10 years now.
I came in in 2004
when Google acquired
a company called
Keyhole and worked
on Google Earth and Google
Maps a really long time
before we started a
project called Niantic.
And with Niantic,
we've been working
to create games that happen
out in the real world,
and that bend fiction and
mobile gameplay in a new way.
"Ingress" is the game
that's out there right now.
And the next big thing for us is
this project called "Endgame."
James called.
Actually, his agents called
me a couple years ago
and said that James
wanted to I talk to me.
And I didn't know who
James was at the time,
but I quickly did some
research and found out
that he's a very
established author,
wrote a book called "A
Million Little Pieces,"
"New York Times" best
seller, critically acclaimed.
"Bright Shiny Morning," another
critically acclaimed book--
probably my favorite of
James' what he calls, I guess,
"big boy fiction."
As I got to know James
better, I learned
that he worked in Hollywood.
He directed movies,
wrote movies,
made movies out here
for about 10 years
before moving to the East Coast
to become a real, bona fide,
critically acclaimed novelist.
What I also learned
is that he has
this really innovative approach
to writing and developing
fictions.
He created this company
called Full Fathom Five,
employs a lot of writers
in this collaborative way.
And they've written a lot
of young adult fiction,
including "I am
Number Four," which
was a movie that
James co-developed
and produced with
Steven Spielberg.
But they also had developed
games and audiobooks that
accompany the novels, and done
some incredibly innovative
things with technology.
And James explained
that he was conceiving
of this project that,
from the very beginning,
would create a universe that
would unfold though novels
and through movies, and
through mobile games.
And he basically pitched me
kind of the exact same things
that we had been talking
about inside Niantic.
But the cool thing
was, it was coming
from a world-class creative
who had this already
stellar reputation as a
novelist and writer and somebody
deeply intertwined with the
film and movie industry.
And I thought it was really
the perfect opportunity for us
to take this technology
we've been working on,
and to marry it with
a world-class creative
and to see what we
can invent in terms
of a new form of storytelling.
And we're well into that.
We have a site up now
called Ancient Society.
It's where the first glimpse
of what we've been working on
is out there, and a game that
will come out next year that
will reinforce the novel.
But I think James is here to
talk more about all of that.
So I'll turn it
over to you, sir.
JAMES FREY: Thanks.
I think John just said
everything I was going to say.
I have a weird history
with this building.
It's always cool to
be here, because I
used to live-- I lived
in LA for a long time.
And I lived five blocks from
here, from 1994 to 2002.
And I met my now wife when she
was working here at Chiat/Day
making commercials for Apple.
And so I often used to
walk over and pick her up
at the end of her work day.
And we would walk to--
there were very fewer bars
and restaurants around
here in the '90s.
But we would walk to one
of them and hang out.
And I love coming
to this building.
I love coming to this
building because of that.
And I love coming to this
building because of Google.
It was in this building
where John I first
met a couple of years ago.
We cold-called them.
I had heard of Niantic
and had done some research
into "Ingress."
And I was fascinated by it.
And I thought it was the future.
And that's what I
am trying to do,
is build the future-- not
build the future of technology,
but build the future of
storytelling and entertainment
and how a storyteller can
use the technological tools
at our disposal now to
tell better stories, deeper
stories, more immersive stories,
more interesting and exciting
stories.
"Endgame" started, in a way,
when I was 10 years old.
I grew up in Cleveland.
And one day my mom brought home
this book called "Masquerade,"
which was a book by a
dude named Kip Williams.
He was an English painter.
And he had written this book
that was 16 pages of text,
and it had 16 paintings in it.
And embedded into the text and
the paintings were a puzzle.
If you could solve
the puzzle, it
led you somewhere
to the location
on Earth where he had buried
a solid gold, jewel-encrusted
rabbit worth $50,000.
As a 10-year-old, I had
dreams of solving this puzzle
and buying a giant
stack of "Star Wars"
action figures and
Atari cartridges.
And I became obsessed
with the book,
and I read it over and
over and over again.
And what I loved about
it was it somehow
was a book that became
more than a book.
Usually a book is a static
object and a static experience.
You sit somewhere and you read
it, and it exists on the pages
and it exists in your mind.
What I loved about
"Masquerade" is it somehow
became more than that.
It made me think about
it everywhere I went.
It made me look around
the world and wonder.
I knew in my 10-year-old
mind that the rabbit
wasn't buried in my schoolyard,
but I still wondered.
I knew it wasn't buried
in my neighbor's backyard,
but I still wondered.
It somehow became more
than a book to me.
And it took somebody
three years to solve
the puzzle of "Masquerade."
The rabbit turned out to be
buried at the foot of a tree
where an ancient
English King was
rumored to have been beheaded.
And then the world sort
of forgot about it.
I never did.
I always thought
about "Masquerade."
I always wanted to try to do
something like "Masquerade."
Like John said, I have
a weird work history.
I went to art school.
I moved to LA.
I worked in the film
business for a long time.
I wrote some movies.
I directed a couple movies.
I produced some movies.
When I was 30 and I was
living right down the street,
I'd always-- the dream had
always been to write books.
I quit, and I wrote a book.
I wrote "A Million Little
Pieces" right over there.
It came out.
I was lucky enough
that it did well,
and I was able to not go
back into the film business,
just write books.
I did that for 10 years.
So I worked in the film
business for about 10 years,
and then I wrote books
for about 10 years.
And at the end of
that sort of run,
I was bored with writing books.
I was bored with
writing normal books.
And then these things
started appearing.
I think these are
extraordinary devices
that we take for granted.
I hold this thing in
my hand, whether it's
an iPhone or a Nexus device,
whatever smartphone you use.
And I have all the world's
knowledge at my fingertips
at all times.
I can learn anything
about anything
within about five seconds.
I can see a picture of
any location on Earth
within about five seconds.
I can see a mapping
coordinate, and get directions
to anywhere on earth
within about five seconds.
I can take pictures.
I can watch videos.
I can play games.
I can call people.
I can text people.
I can engage in social media.
It's an extraordinary thing.
If you went back in time with
this and handed it to somebody,
they wouldn't
believe it existed.
As a storyteller, I
thought about how could I
start using the technology
embedded within this thing
to make better stories?
How could I take a
book and expand it
out using the technology?
It sounds like a weird
idea, but I sort of
had this idea when
I was searching
for something on Google.
And an odd search
result came up.
And I thought that would be cool
to somehow link out of a book.
You're reading a book.
You pop a link on
a digital book.
It takes you to a
search result that
somehow illuminates whatever
it was you were reading.
From there, I started thinking
about "Masquerade" again.
I started thinking about a
puzzle embedded within a book.
And instead of just doing it
within the pages of the book,
like Kip Williams
did, somehow trying
to do it using all of
these technological tools
that were now at my
disposal as a storyteller.
From there, I started thinking
about what kind of story
could I tell?
What story would work?
What story would be a cool book
that I could use technology
with that would tell a story,
that could have a puzzle?
And then I started thinking
sort of further than
that-- that I could build
a mobile game with-- I play
mobile games-- that I
could make movies out of,
that I could build
a universe out of.
I like conspiracy theories.
I like aliens.
So I started looking at
a lot of stuff like that.
What I'll start to tell
you now-- some of it's
real information.
Some of it's fake.
I'm a master at
blending those things.
So I will be very
clear with you when
I'm jumping back and forth.
Real information-- human
beings that look like us
have existed for 200,000 years.
Human beings that
think like us have only
existed for 12,000 years.
This was discovered
in 2003, 2004
by the Human Genome Project.
After they fully
decoded the genome,
they started going
backwards in time
to look at the DNA of people
from different periods of time,
to see how we had evolved,
if we had evolved at all.
They reached a point
12,000 years ago
where something happened to
the genetics of our brain.
Two genes from opposite
ends of the gene spectrum
were moved and fused, and it
made us significantly smarter
and greatly enhanced
our cognitive abilities.
There's no explanation for it.
Nobody knows how it
happened or who did it.
The only thing they've
ever seen like it
is when they genetically
engineer animals
in their own labs.
That's a fact.
The same time that happened,
all the world's earliest
civilizations were formed.
They were formed in the
Middle East, in India,
in China, in South America,
in North America-- all at
about the same time.
All of those earliest
civilizations
were formed around gold mines.
Nobody has any idea
why this happened.
Gold's not a functional metal.
You can't make a hammer out
of it or an axe out of it
or a knife out of it.
It's not particularly
rare or hard to get.
It's beautiful, but there
are other beautiful things
in the world.
But all the world's
early civilizations
were formed around gold mines.
At the same time those
two things happened,
all of the world's earliest
origin myths were born.
And they all say almost
identically the same thing,
which is that our omnipotent
creators descended from the sky
amid smoke and fire, created
humanity, gave us rules
to live by, and then left.
But before leaving, they told
us someday they would come back.
And when they did,
the world would end.
So as a storyteller, I see that
information, which is all real,
and I think it's cool.
And it makes me think, well,
12,000 years ago, aliens
came to Earth because they
discovered gold was here.
And they needed it,
for whatever reason.
And they saw these
grunting animals
that bashed each other
over the heads with sticks,
and they decided to
genetically engineer
us to make us a little bit
smarter so they could organize
us into a labor force so
we could dig up their gold.
When they had the
gold, they took off.
For my fiction I said,
before they took off--
or for my fiction,
what I have them doing
is starting 12 original
civilizations around the world.
The reason I chose
the number 12 is
because multiple religions and
multiple ancient civilizations
use that number.
They use it in the Bible.
They use it in the Koran.
They use it in China.
They use it in Japan.
They all say humanity descended
from 12 original civilizations
or tribes.
In the book, we use the
oldest civilizations on Earth.
We vary in a very
calculated way.
We chose ancient civilizations,
but we also chose civilizations
from all over the world,
so somehow it was balanced.
And what we say is the aliens
told these civilizations
that when they
returned, a game would
be played to determine
the future of humanity
and that they had
to keep somebody
under the age of 20 prepared
to play this game at all times.
So for thousands and
thousands of years,
these civilizations, all of
which are extinct, all of which
have vanished, have
actually lived on in secret
and kept people prepared
to play the game.
In the book, we say that
a lot of the world's
secret societies-- things like
the Brotherhood of the Snake
or the Illuminati
or the Rosicrucians
or the Priory of Sion--
are, in fact, real.
But they are not devoted
to world domination.
They're devoted
to keeping players
prepared to play Endgame.
All the players knew, all
the civilizations knew,
was that the game
would be kicked off
by a celestial event.
So they waited.
At the beginning
of the first book,
12 asteroids simultaneously
hit Earth's surface.
They do trillions of
dollars of damage and kill
millions of people.
Most people on Earth
think it's a fluke,
except for these players, who
know that Endgame just started.
Switch back to real
information for a second.
There's a pyramid in China.
It's called the Great
White Pyramid of Xian.
It is built to the precise
dimensions of the Great Pyramid
at Giza, except it's
three times larger.
They know at one point
the pyramid at Giza
was covered with white limestone
and had a gold cap on it.
The pyramid in China is still
covered with white limestone
and has a gold cap on it.
Chinese government doesn't
let anyone near it--
doesn't let anybody
within 100 miles of it.
Last time it was
seen was in 1945,
when US fighter pilots
flew over it and took
a bunch of pictures of it.
If you Google that,
you'll see the pictures.
The Chinese government
doesn't discuss
why they don't let
anybody near it
or what they think
happens there.
They just don't.
In the book, the players
go to this pyramid,
where they're met by an
alien, who tells them
that Endgame is the
hunt for three keys,
that three keys have been
hidden around the world.
They have to be found in order.
And the first
player to physically
possess those three
keys wins the game.
What they win is the
apocalypse is coming,
and the slice of humanity
descended from the winner's
civilization will survive
the impending apocalypse.
Everybody on Earth
is going to die.
Does that all make sense?
So I have that story framework.
I have a story
that I think works,
that I think is cool, that
blends real information
with fictional information,
and that gives me a framework
to build what I call a 21st
century book, or a 21st century
entertainment
franchise-- a puzzle,
a mobile game, a series of
movies and television shows,
novellas, social
media-- almost limitless
what we could do with it.
From there I wrote the book.
I knew there was going to
be a ton of labor involved
in doing this project, more than
anything I'd ever done before.
So I found a friend of mine
to write the book with me.
I wrote a 30-page outline
in a 50-page sort of Bible,
handed it to him.
He wrote the first
draft of the book.
From there, I rewrote
the book three times.
And the book was finished.
The book was finished about two
and a half, three years ago.
Once the book was finished,
it was, OK, how do I do this?
And I had written out
how I wanted to do it
in this sort of Bible document.
And the first partner
I wanted to get
was Google, for a
variety of reasons.
One of them because
I had seen "Ingress."
I hadn't seen it.
I had heard of it and read
about it and knew what it was,
and it very much
matched up with my idea
of how to make a mobile
version of "Endgame."
B, when I wanted to build
the puzzle for the book,
I wanted to be use
Google's App Engines
for a variety of reasons.
But I also wanted
to use Google itself
and build a book that, when you
read it, you're reading along.
And you'll come-- in a physical
book, it's a footnoted word.
In a digital book, it's
a hyperlinked word.
And you click it, and it
would take you out somewhere
into Google, to a Google search
result, to a YouTube video,
to a Google map location,
to a Google Earth location,
to a book fragment, to a field
trip excursion-- a book that,
when you read it, the
same way "Masquerade"
took me out of it into
a different world,
took you out of it
into a different world,
and used all of these things--
search results, YouTube videos,
locations-- as a way to
enhance the story and deepen
the story-- social media
accounts, Google+ profiles.
I called John, or my
agent called John.
He works up in San
Francisco, I work
in New York and
Connecticut, so we met here.
We had a one-hour meeting
scheduled originally,
that turned into a three or
four-hour conversation with him
and a couple of the
guys-- who I think
are in this room-- who
work on "Ingress," a couple
of the story puzzle guys.
And from there,
it was, all right,
how do we start building this?
It was remarkable meeting
John because, like he said,
we were thinking about
exactly the same things
but from different
points of view.
He's a technologist.
He knows how to build
things and do things
that I don't and that are way
beyond any version of what
my brain can do.
But I knew how to
do things he didn't.
I know how to tell stories.
I know how to set up
entertainment deals.
I know how to make movies
and television shows.
And in many ways, it
was a perfect marriage
of complementary skills.
From there, we started working
on the game and the puzzle.
I'm not smart enough
to write the puzzle,
so I hired a couple
guys with PhDs from MIT
to write the puzzle.
We built the puzzle, which
exists exactly like I always
conceived of it-- in a
variety of places on Google
and then about 100
to 150 websites
that are all built and linked
using Google's App Engines.
And we started building
the mobile game.
And just like "Ingress,"
if you play "Ingress"--
and I would imagine-- how
many of you play "Ingress"?
A lot of you play "Ingress."
The thing about "Ingress"
that snapped for me
is, I was talking about a book
being a static experience.
Most video games are
also a static experience.
It's you get a game, you
sit in front of a screen,
and you don't move.
You engage the game on a screen,
and that's where it exists.
If it goes anywhere,
it goes to a place
where you might interact
with other players
in different parts
of the world online.
But it's still a static,
non-moving experience.
My idea was, for
"Endgame," how do we turn
the world into a video game?
How do we build a game that
you can play everywhere you go,
that you don't play
sitting on your couch?
You play when you're walking
to school, when you're
going to the grocery
store, when you're sitting
at a stoplight in
a car, when you're
in a line to get your
driver's license-- whatever.
How do we turn the
world into a video game?
And that's essentially what
they were doing with "Ingress."
They figured out a way to
make a game that forced people
to get up off their ass and
go do stuff and interact
with each other and play against
each other and choose a team.
And on top of that,
they were building
fiction that went
along with that game
and went along with that idea.
So not only are you
getting up off your ass
to play a game that you
can do everywhere you
go, there's an ongoing story
that lets you interact with it,
that lets you participate in
it, that lets you choose a side
and have a team and
work with other people
to win or lose while
playing the game.
It's the future, absolutely.
You know, the technology
lets us do this.
So John and I started
talking about, OK,
how do we do it with "Endgame"?
How do we take lessons
learned from "Ingress"
and apply them to "Endgame"
while also making it
something different and
new and more exciting,
hopefully-- not that
"Ingress" isn't exciting.
And we spent a long
time talking about it.
He started hiring people.
From there, I took the
book out to publishers.
We sold it to 35
publishers in 34 languages.
When it was released,
it was the largest
simultaneous publication
of a book in history.
It came out in 34 languages and
165 countries on the same day.
We built the puzzle.
The puzzle was
enormously complicated,
not only in its conception and
execution, both on the page
and off the page, but
incredibly complicated legally.
We had to figure out
how to do something that
was legal in 165 countries.
And then from there, once we
had the publishers, the puzzle,
and John's team working on the
game, and John's hiring people
to build out a team even bigger,
we sold the movie rights.
20th Century Fox
bought the movie rights
in the biggest rights
acquisition deal
in the studio's long history.
The producers are a
group of two men who
call themselves Temple Hill.
They made all the
"Twilight" movies.
They made "The
Fault in Our Stars."
They made "Maze Runner."
They're old, old
buddies of mine.
And now this
actually might work.
We have a book.
The book came out in October.
It hit the best seller
list in 12 languages
in about 30 countries.
A book that's going
to be a game that's
going to be a movie that
will have ongoing-- it
will have fiction that
we write in the books.
But just like "Ingress," it
will have ongoing fiction
and new puzzles that allow
the readers and the gamers
to interact with the
characters, to feel
like they're participating
in it, to help
us shape where it goes.
Right now the books and the
ARG fiction are separate.
But we've been working
a lot to fuse them.
So in the next book, which
comes out next October,
they'll start to fuse.
And then by the time the
third book comes out,
the October after that,
it will be fully fused.
And what I think we
believe we're doing
is building the future
of entertainment,
of books and of
gaming and of films
and of how those things
are-- instead of allowing
them to happen accidentally.
And when I say
accidentally, you look
at something like Harry Potter.
They didn't plan for Harry
Potter to be what was.
It happened, it came
out, it exploded,
and then they built a
whole world around it
after its success.
My idea from the
beginning of this
was that we could create that
world from the beginning,
and people would come
to it-- that instead
of waiting to see what happened,
we build it and they come.
And that's what we're doing.
It's been crazy
exciting, a ton of work,
not too stressful,
actually, because you get up
excited and kind of
scared every day,
which is what I think the best
way to feel about your job is.
Yeah, and it's been amazing.
I get to work with
a ton of people
who are a lot smarter
than me and who
know a lot more about
things that I don't know.
And I think it's
actually going to work.
I think we're going
to pull it off.
Any questions?
No questions?
All you smart people
and no questions?
AUDIENCE: This sounds amazing.
I was so excited to
come in this morning.
This is great.
My question for you is,
how much of a leap of faith
was it when you
started this project?
Because with a
Harry Potter book,
you start out with a book.
You work with a
publisher to publish it,
and then it just kind
of grows from there.
So you have a basis of success.
With something like "Endgame,"
it's a great concept.
But it sounds to me you had
to employ a lot of people
from the get-go to
sign onto this project
before it could ever
be fiscally feasible.
So if you could talk a
little bit about the business
aspect of it in addition
to the creative aspect.
JAMES FREY: I mean, really
it was just convincing people
that my vision was possible.
It was getting into
rooms with people
who could make this
thing a reality
and convincing them that
it was possible to do.
One thing I did was,
the book was done.
And there was a sort of
controlling plan document.
So I wasn't just coming
in and saying, well,
this is what I want to do.
You want to do it?
I could say, this is
what I want to do.
Here is the plan very precisely.
Here's what I need.
Here's what I would like to
do with you specifically.
And here's the book.
You can read it.
I mean, people took
real leaps of faith.
I mean, I was convincing
people to spend real money
and put in real work.
And I don't know what to
say other than that I think
a lot of-- I didn't
know John, but I
knew everybody else I went to.
I had worked with them before.
HarperCollins published the
book in the United States.
They published one of my adult
novels before and about 40
of my company's books.
So it's a very longstanding,
stable, productive
relationship.
Marty and Wick, the
movie producers,
are guys-- Marty used to be
one of my agents 15 years ago.
And they're guys I've
known since I first
started writing movies
out here a long time ago.
I worked for Wick.
And then as far as
making deals, I always
say, like, just look at
what the greater good is.
I'm not going to fight
you and bitch and moan
about a little deal point.
The idea is to make this
happen-- to prove it out.
And if we can make it happen and
we prove it out and it works,
everybody's going to be
very happy financially.
But that if I get hung
up over stupid bullshit,
I put it in jeopardy.
When you make a
partnership with anybody,
whether it's a business
partnership or a friendship
or a marriage or whatever,
you take a leap of faith.
And for me, I don't need
to control everything.
I don't have to be in
charge of everything.
You have to believe in the
people you're working with
or you're in partnership with.
And if I've done anything
well on this project,
it's choose great partners.
Like, I think the guys,
John and Dan and Jim,
the whole team here at
Google-- I always am
super-excited when I come here.
A, because the
cafeteria fucking rocks.
B, because I get all the
free Coke Zero I want.
But C, because I
walk in, and I know
I'm going to spend my day with
people-- and I don't say this,
like, jokingly or
in a corny way.
I'm going to work with people
who I really, truly believe
are smarter than me and who
are awesome at their jobs.
They're the best people in
the world at their jobs.
And we're doing
exciting, fun stuff.
And every time I come-- it's
not like I'm here every day.
Every time I come, there's
something new happening.
They have something new to show
me, something new to tell me.
And I would be a fool and a
madman to walk in here and try
to tell them that I
know more than them,
because I just don't.
You work with the
best people you can
and you let them do their
job and you trust them.
And then honestly, you
let them know how much you
appreciate working with them.
It's been great.
The partners have
all been great.
We do events together
all the time.
We did-- me, John, and Marty
Bone did an event last night.
We've done events all
over the place together.
Always a pleasure
to see everybody.
I'm always stoked.
And like I said, I get
up excited most days.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
But my question
is, were you aware
that there was
scandal surrounding
the end of "Masquerade?"
JAMES FREY: Was I aware that
there was a scandal surrounding
the end of "Masquerade"?
I was.
So the scandal surrounding
the end of "Masquerade"
was that the winner of the
prize was the new boyfriend
of the author's ex-girlfriend.
Does that make sense?
So clearly, there was some kind
of inside shit going on there.
One of the things we did
with "Endgame" was we
went to great
lengths to make sure
that that was not possible.
I don't know where
the key is hidden.
The way the puzzle works, Matt
[? Lebowitz ?] and his team,
which is sometimes three
people and sometimes
20 people-- I'm never
sure how many he
has working for him at any
given time-- built the puzzle.
Matt knows the solution to the
puzzle, and one of my attorneys
knows the solution
to the puzzle.
Nobody else does.
The way the actual
mechanics of the puzzle work
is, when you solve one of the
first puzzles in the books,
it will take you
one of two websites.
Once you're there, you sign in.
You have to have
a Google account.
So if you don't have a Gmail
address, you have to start one.
You accept our privacy policy.
You accept our rules.
From there, part of
our privacy policy
allows us to track
you everywhere
you go-- only when you're
engaged in our websites
or engaged in the puzzle.
So if you're on a puzzle website
trying to solve a puzzle,
we know where you are.
We know how long
you've been there.
We know what you're doing.
We can do that with
every player on Earth.
Last I checked, there were
players or people actively
working to solve the
puzzle from 104 countries,
and over 100,000
people had solved
the first entry-level
puzzle and are working.
There was a group of, let's
say, 20,000 people who spend
multiple hours a day on it.
And there was a group of
about 10 who were in the lead.
But we will know where they
are, what they're doing,
and we will know
when somebody wins.
When somebody solves it, there
will be one person who does it.
We'll be able to prove it.
We'll be able to print out
an entire record of how they
got there, how long it took
them, what steps they took,
in order to both
prove that it was fair
and ensure that it was fair.
And people ask me all the
time, like, where's the key?
I don't know.
For a while, I actually
had the key in my wallet.
For the first three weeks
after the book came out,
the whole puzzle was
built, but we knew,
or we believed nobody would
solve it that quickly.
So I was walking around
with this key in my wallet.
And I would pull it out
at events, and be like,
here's the fucking key.
And I'm not sure-- I don't
know if you guys were
at any of those events.
I'm not sure if people believed
me or not, but it was the key.
Once you find the key,
the gold, the prize
is $500,000 for the first
book-- $500,000 in gold.
For the second book,
it will be $1 million.
For the third book,
it'll be $1.5 million.
The gold is in a
bulletproof case
bolted to the floor of
Caesar's Palace in Las Vegas.
So when you find the key, you
will go to Caesar's Palace.
You'll open that case.
It's actually hydraulic, so you
put the key in, you turn it,
and the hydraulic
case will lift up.
And you get to
sweep away the gold,
and do whatever
you want with it.
AUDIENCE: Is it
going to be taxed?
JAMES FREY: That's actually
a very valid question,
and one we had to deal with.
And in the rules
of the game, we say
we are not responsible
for you, your taxes,
or your interactions with the
government of your country
in any way whatsoever, that once
the golden moves physically out
of the case into
your possession,
it is your business.
If you happen to win
it, I would highly
advise you pay your taxes.
But it's got nothing
to do with me.
AUDIENCE: When do you
expect someone to win it?
It sounds like you're
expecting a winner
before the next book comes out.
JAMES FREY: We
don't really know.
We wanted to design
the puzzle so
that it took approximately
10 to 12 months for somebody
to solve it.
It's, again, one of those
things you can't really control.
You can build it in a way that
you think will take that long,
but you can't control it.
Right now, it's on track
to happen somewhere
within that window.
Right out of the gate, people
were slightly ahead of pace.
Then people fell
slightly behind pace.
Right now, I think
they're right on pace.
I think it'll get solved
in August or September
of next year,
which will be right
before the next book comes out.
But I don't know.
I know nobody's solved it
yet, which makes me happy.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] next book.
JAMES FREY: Yeah, we're
not stupid that way.
Couple more.
AUDIENCE: Is it
hard to catch up?
JAMES FREY: It's not
actually hard to catch up,
I don't think.
I mean, I haven't done it.
I'm not trying to solve it.
As part of the rules,
I can't win it, so--
and I'm also busy enough that
I don't have the time to do it.
But I think it's
possible to catch up.
I know people are
sharing information.
And I think it's
possible to catch up.
AUDIENCE: Will the game
that's being built,
will that be part
of finding the key?
JAMES FREY: No.
We talked about that early on.
But legally it was
way too complicated.
One company needed to take
responsibility for the puzzle.
I don't think Google wanted
to indemnify either me
or the puzzle builders.
Google didn't become Google
because the people running
it are stupid.
So we talked about that
very, very early on.
But it was way too complicated
to do for a variety of reasons.
So no, but there
are still puzzles
that are part of the ARG
fiction related to the game that
are totally awesome,
in that you can
go in and try to solve them.
And once the game comes out,
when you solve those puzzles,
it'll give you
rewards in the game.
It'll give you better
weapons, or better armor,
or better skills.
So there will be puzzles in
the game that provide you
with rewards but not
clues to the puzzle that
wins you the money.
AUDIENCE: In the game, do you
get to create a character--
did you put a character
in Endgame, so--
JAMES FREY: You do.
You get to choose a line.
And you have a username.
And you get to choose what
your character's wearing.
And you get to go
out on missions,
sort of like "Ingress," and
find the weapons you want.
And then you get to go
do battle with people.
They showed us an animation
of the game yesterday,
of one of the battles happening.
It's going to be pretty awesome.
It's going to be really cool.
AUDIENCE: So with
your friends, you
could make alliances
and then go [INAUDIBLE]?
JAMES FREY: You can.
Like, in a few
months, the two of you
will be able to
make an alliance.
And if there's some
11-year-old boy in your class
you don't like-- and
he's really annoying,
and he's also playing
"Endgame," the two
of you will be able to gang
up on him and take him out.
And if and when you
do that, you have
to send your dad an email so
that he can send it to me,
because I want to hear about it.
AUDIENCE: So we were talking
about a book being [INAUDIBLE]
something that's more not
just unbounded from the page,
but I think also unbounded
from the-- part of a book
is you lock yourself in.
You get all the creative
vision out into it.
And I think with ARGs and
things like that, you're
dealing with the way it
interacts with the world
and how that
affects the back end
and the cycle of creativity.
Has that come into play
within "Endgame" yet?
Are you seeing interaction
having that feedback
into the future?
If not--
JAMES FREY: It has not,
but we believe it will.
And we're sort of
planning for it to.
One of the things with
the ARG and the book
is the first book was done and
was on a publication schedule
before we even started
any of the ARG fiction.
So there's no way we can reverse
engineer it back into it.
There have been a
lot of conversations
and a lot of emails
about book two.
And there's a draft of book two.
There's a pretty tight
working draft of book two
about how to integrate the
ARG fiction into the book.
And so in book two,
like I said, there
will be a lot of-- the
characters from the ARG
are starting to
appear in the book.
By the time book three has to be
finished, the ARG and the game
will be out.
And there will be
real participation,
we hope and believe.
And there'll be real feedback.
And we'll be able to
integrate it far more into it.
The other thing is,
we can do novellas.
We have eight novellas
finished right now.
But we can produce novellas
very, very quickly.
And so part of the
idea is that we'll
be able to produce
novellas within, let's say,
two to four weeks of events
in the game happening.
And because with a
novella we're not
tied to a traditional
physical publishing schedule,
if an event happens in
the game and the ARG,
we can pop out a novella.
And we can publish
it immediately.
So fans and players
and readers will
be able to get material in ways
that they never have before.
And part of that is because
we built a system to be--
or my company built a system--
to be able to produce material
that quickly and efficiently.
And digital publishing
lets us do it.
Once we have a
manuscript done, it's
maybe three, four
hours to format it
into the proper files.
We already have all
the accounts set up
with all the digital
distributors-- Google, Apple,
Amazon, Barnes and Noble.
It's just a matter of setting
up a page for the novella
and releasing it.
So there will be a lot of that.
That's one of the most exciting
parts of this whole thing
is we'll be doing
storytelling in real time
with technology in ways that
nobody's ever done it before.
It's one of the exciting
parts and scary parts.
But that's definitely the plan.
One more question?
Two more questions?
All right, I've
silenced the Googlers.
AUDIENCE: So in
the game, it sounds
like you have to choose a line.
JAMES FREY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If you don't choose
the same line as your friends,
are you going to be
able to play together?
JAMES FREY: You will.
There will be ways
to-- different lines
will be able to align
with other lines.
So there will-- and
then you will also
be able to betray them.
You'll have advantages
over certain lines.
You'll have disadvantages
And you'll be able to align with
some people from other lines.
AUDIENCE: So the people
I want to play with,
I should pick the
same line as them.
JAMES FREY: Or you
should just-- you'll
be able to see what lines
you can align yourself with.
Just choose complementary lines.
Or if they're, like, more
a frenemy than a friend,
choose a line where you
have advantages over,
and you get to go wipe them out.
AUDIENCE: For the
game, could you--
are you going to be
traveling not on your device?
Do you have to travel places
to unlock special things?
Or do you do that in the game?
JAMES FREY: Well, in this
game, one big difference
between "Ingress"
is you can unlock
certain things by buying them.
But make sure your dad
says it's OK first.
But yes, you'll be
traveling on foot.
You'll be just like "Ingress."
That's one of the greatest--
if anything-- you know,
that's one of the greatest
things about "Ingress."
The great, radical step
that "Ingress" took
is that it gets you
out into the world.
You're not sitting in a
chair playing a video game.
You have to play it.
You have to go out in the world.
And we definitely-- that was
one of the things I thought
was awesome about it and
one of the reasons I called.
So thank you very,
very much for coming.
I'm stoked, as
always, to be here.
And I hope you get
a copy of the book.
And I hope you read it.
And I hope you dig it.
And when the game comes out, I
hope you play it and love it.
And check out
ancientsocieties.com
where all the ARG fiction is.
There's a ton of awesome
material on there already.
And there's only more coming.
And yeah, go Google.
[APPLAUSE]